[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it seems like
even after a week of its release
stranger things is still sending
people's understanding of the ending
upside down throughout this video I'll
be discussing the secret hidden message
in the show as well as breaking down
what it could mean about the true fate
of our hero Jim hopper there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
watched all of stranger things through
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking the video
I hope you enjoy it now let's get into
my breakdown of the secret stranger
things 3 message
okay so stranger things 3 is nobly ended
with Jim Hoppa played by David Harbor
apparently dying after being caught in
the blast caused by the destruction of
the Russian weapon that had been used to
create a tear to the upside-down Papa's
death was a really heartbreaking moment
in the show that had massive
ramifications for everyone especially 11
who went to live with Joyce and her
family however there was a post-credits
scene that showcased that everything
might not be as it seems and it looks
like there are more hidden messages
within the show that confirmed the
character could still be out there
those who follow harbor on instagram may
have noticed that after the season
premiere that he had begun changing his
profile picture to a set of numbers
every day their overall read 6 186 it
seemed like quite a strange message to
put out on the Internet
however eagle-eyed viewers have went
back and noticed that they have some
significance to the show the numbers are
actually the first few digits of Marie
Bowman's phone number from the show
which is as follows six one a six two
five a three one three this telephone
numbers actually live over the weekend
and a lot of people rang it up to see if
there was a secret Easter Egg for it
well it turns out there was and before
the number was cut up the following
message from Morita Joyce played on it
hi you have reached the residence of
Marie Bowman mum if this is you please
hang up and call me between hours of
5:00 and 6:00 p.m. as previously
discussed okay
if this is Joyce Joyce thank you for
calling I've been trying to reach you I
have an update it's about well it's
probably best if we speak in person it's
not good or bad but it's something this
is of course in reference to Jim hopper
and offers a lot more hope that he's out
there somewhere having escaped to the
upside down and making it to come
chapter it also clears up the fan theory
that Murray is the American in the cell
as had he been captured that he wouldn't
have been able to leave this behind it
seems like more and more that we are
getting mounting evidence that Jim Hoppa
is alive and out there somewhere and
this once again cements it for me that
he's still in the land of the living
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this news and if you agree that
hopper is still alive comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of all
the evidence that supports that hopper
is still breathing which would be linked
at the end in it I go over all of the
theory as well as the hints that the
show leaves to back it up so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more I'll leave that linked
at the end and I just want to let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of Avengers and game to one lucky winner
and all you have to do is like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the theory in the comments below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then to ever get to the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]